Which is less-- the unit rate
of the equation y equals 6.5x
or the unit rate of
the graph shown below?
So when they're talking
about unit rate--
and they're actually a
little bit ambiguous here.
They should have been
clearer in this question.
I'm assuming they're
asking us about the unit
rate at which y changes
with respect to x.
Or how much does y
change for a change of 1
in x, the unit rate.
And over here, you
see when x changes 1,
y is going to change by 6.5.
Every time x increases by 1,
y is going to increase by 6.5.
Or you could say the unit rate
of change of y with respect
to x is 6.5 for
every 1 change in x.
In this graph right over
here, as x changes 1,
as x increases 1, y increases it
looks like by about 3 and 1/2.
x increases by 1, y
increases by 3 and 1/2.
So the unit rate
of change here of y
with respect to x is 3 and 1/2
for every unit increase in x.
So this line is increasing at a
slower rate than this equation.
Or y in this line is increasing
at a slower rate with respect
to x than y is increasing with
respect to x in this equation
right over here.
So the unit rate of
the graph is less
than the unit rate
of the equation.